All right, yes guys, welcome back to
another video. And today, we're going to
be going over how to properly manage
your trade when you're in your life
position. How to go break even, when not
to go break even, how to trail your stop
loss correctly, when to close out your
TP, all of these different things you
need to know how to properly manage when
you're in these positions because some
of you guys know how to execute the
model. Got many videos on how to
execute, that's not an issue. When
you're actually in the trade, some of
you are going wrong. So, let's get
straight into it. Okay, I know I'm
covering a lot of the screen here, so
I'll move my face cam as far into the
corner as I can so you guys can still
see me and see the screen, too. What
actually is break even? So, what
actually is break even? What does it
mean? Going break even means when you
end up with no net profit and no net
loss after accounting for all trades and
costs. So, after all of your executions,
back where you started. You haven't lost
anything, you haven't made anything. And
there are a few common ways that traders
use the term. So, on a single trade, you
move your stop loss to your entry price.
So, the worst-case outcome is roughly
zero loss. And then, that's excluding
the fees and slippage cuz you're going
to have a few commission fees when you
do take trades, but that's only a couple
dollars. And then, for example, let's
say you buy 100, price rises to 105, and
you move your stop loss to 100. If price
reverses and hits the stop, you're break
even. That's it, you haven't made
anything. For example, if you risk 100
pounds to make you need a 50% win rate
to be break even. So, you're going to
have to have a 50% win rate in order to
not lose any money on a one-to-one risk
reward. But, let's say you go for what I
usually go for, which is a one-to-two
risk reward. So, let's say you're
risking 100 pounds to make 200 pounds or
100 dollars to make 200 dollars, you
need a 33% win rate to be break even.
So, anything above a 33% win rate,
you're profitable. And the same for a
one-to-one RR, if you're anything above
a 50% win rate, you're profitable.
That's it. So, you know, many traders
aim to protect break even once a trade
moves into their favor by moving stops
too early. It can also cause good trades
to exit prematurely. So, you can
actually be in a winning position, but
price then comes down, takes you out,
and then it goes to your take profit,
and you wonder how that's happened.
Well, that's exactly why we're making
this video to make sure that happens as
minimal as possible. Obviously,
sometimes you're going to have points
where it does stop you at break even,
and then it goes, but most of the time
it shouldn't. Yeah, it shouldn't. So,
why do we go break even  reduce
risk? So,
day traders go break even mainly to
protect capital and reduce risk once a
trade's already moved in our favor. The
idea is, you know, if the market's
already proven to me partially, right? I
don't want this trade turning into a
full loss, which is, you know, it's fair
enough. It's fair enough. And common
reasons traders move a trade to break
even, protect mental capital. So, you
know, in your mind, so it's like this
next sign, psychologically easier to
trade when you know a winning trade can
no longer become a big loser. So, some
people like to do that because it helps
with their mind and them to cope with
the stress of being in a position. But,
the problem with that also, you want to
chase that feeling too soon, and then
that'll actually lead to you having made
nothing on a really good trade, which
actually should have been a winner. And
that's where a lot of people go wrong.
So, although yes, break even is a good
idea, it's definitely a good idea, but
you need to do it at a point where it
makes sense, not where helping you cope
psychologically. In the long run, guys,
you can't just throw break even as soon
as we take the first high, because
you're not leaving enough room for the
trade to breathe. You need to actually
read price action, see what it's telling
you, and let your trade move
algorithmically. Cuz if you're not,
that's how you're going to
miss out on the winning even though you
haven't lost anything, you've still lost
out on the chance to make money. Once
price has taken certain points in
profit, such as a short-term high, such
short-term lows,
you trail your stop loss to the next
point where your trade becomes
invalidated. So, that's what actually
makes sense, not psychologically what
makes sense in your head, but what
you're seeing and what actually makes
sense of what price action's doing. If
it's taking these points of liquidity,
and then price puts in new lows and new
highs, whatever, if you're long or
short, it makes sense to trail to those
next points. Because if price then goes
to take those points, it's then
disrespecting, you know, bullish or
bearish structure, depending on how
you're actually in the position, and
it's then taking that point, which will
then invalidate that structure, and
therefore you're out the position. You
don't want to be in a trade anymore
where it's not actually valid to be
inside of. Does that make sense?
Hopefully so.
So, your mindset during a live position.
When you've taken a position, your only
job as a trader is to make sure your
stop loss and take profit are placed
correctly, to manage your risk as it
moves into a profit or loss. Nothing
else. Nothing else. You just want to
focus on how the trade is running, cuz
we can't control the outcome. Now, you
need to prepare yourself with the amount
of risk you put on, yeah? So, if you're
worried about the position losing,
you're either too attached to the
outcome of the trade and the dollar
amount, therefore you need to detach by
either shifting your mind in that
moment. So, what that means is, right
there and then you're going to tell
yourself, "I don't care what happens.
I'm happy with the risk, and if I lose,
I don't mind. All I care about is
managing the trade correctly and
executing correctly." And if you can't
do that, you've got to be honest with
yourself, then you've either got to
reduce your position size, so the dollar
amount is not affecting you, or go back
to demo until you can hold and manage
positions correctly. And that's really
it, guys. So, let's go into a few live
examples of trades that I've actually
taken. If you don't think I've taken
them live, then go back to the date on
my YouTube channel to find the live
execution there. All right, so first
example, we're here on the 30th of
January. This is the secondary macro, so
you guys want to go back and actually
take a look for yourselves, feel free.
So, clearly we're above side liquidity.
So, in this position, we'd be looking
for shorts. So, what we can see here is
a clear shift in market structure. Is
our bullish order block to the left that
gets inverse. Previous short-term high
to left got taken. So, this is a breaker
block. Breaker block part of the fair
value gap, and then there's the tap of
our gap, running stops at this high for
a one to two risk to reward. How are you
going to manage this position? We have
the first short-term low. First
short-term low, we would mark out, as we
are in shorts. That'll be the first
point we would look the trail our stops.
So, you can mark this out as either TS
or trail
stops. So, at this point, you would then
trail to the next short-term high. So,
we have our stop loss at the most recent
high at this point of buy side, and this
is the next short-term high that's been
put in after taking the most recent
short-term low. So, we're going to
reduce risk just above this high, and
that has significantly reduced the
amount of risk we have on the table. And
you can see it's above this bearish
order block, too. So, it's above the
high and this bearish order block. Two
confluences protecting our stop loss.
So, now, what you'd want to do, identify
where your break even point would be.
So, for me, I'd either look at this
short-term low here, price coming down
to take out this point, or if there's no
short-term low that's actually 50%, so
halfway between your entry point and
your take profit, you can use your
Fibonacci tool, mark out from the entry
to TP, and then this would be your 50%
point, the 0.5 on the fib, and then
you'd want price to take this point and
then put in a bearish fair value gap, so
putting in an imbalance and initiating
that price wants to move lower. Okay, so
as of this point, you would think you'd
want to trail this short-term high after
we've taken this short-term low, this
short-term low. But, in these examples,
guys, you need to realize that we have
one, two previous short-term highs, and
we're at the third one. Now, just from
going break even, you're taking off a
bit more risk, you know, you're making
it completely break even, right? But,
this is a scenario where you need to
think in your head, you know, am I
willing to risk just a couple points and
you know, just above the high compared
to when I was full risk out, right? So,
would I be willing to risk a couple
points just to make sure I'm completely
invalidated if it does stop me out?
Because you have your stop loss above
three previous short-term highs and a
bearish order block and a bearish fair
value gap that hasn't been disrespected
yet. Are you going to really go
completely risk-free, take away the fact
that it could be in a really strong
position, or are you going to leave it
in a position where price is very highly
likely to trade out of those points and
then move lower? So, really depends how
you want to approach it. Obviously, if
my stop loss was up at this point and
there was no previous high to trail at
and it's taken these lows, then I would
go risk free, yes. Because when you're
leaving that much risk on the table, you
know, it's not really worth it,
especially if it's taking points of
liquidity. But, you can see here that we
put in a 0.5 area and I did say yes, we
would have to take out this point in
order to go break even. When price is
taking short-term lows, you then want to
trail to the next previous two
short-term highs. So, that would be
another scenario where you go break
even. So, if it takes the next lows,
you're trailing to the next high. Takes
the next lows, trail to the next high.
And that's how you can just naturally go
to break even without having to take a
50% point of a short-term low or a
short-term high or the Fibonacci. All
right, there we go. So, price has taken
one short-term high, two short-term
highs, and our stop is resting just
above this short-term high and this
bearish order block, which as of now is
perfectly respected. So, let's see where
it moves from this point. And there we
go, perfectly respecting those
confluences and then it then takes this
short-term low, which is also a bullish
order block. So, what I wanted to see is
after it took this low and it failed to
close below it, it's respecting this
bullish order block. So, that's where I
then move to risk free and I'll just
break even on this position. I wanted to
see price run lower. So, you go, respect
that bullish order block, but now we
then traded out of this bearish order
block, inverse that bullish one, and now
we have bearish structure coming out
again. So, now what you can see is,
okay, so from this point now, I actually
closed out early due to the S&P 500
taking this point of sell side. I'm not
going to hold out on that trade any
longer if I don't think it's going to go
to my take profit. Simply by looking at
the points of sell side it's taken and
that it's high probability to go higher.
And are you really going to risk a
couple points just to hit your full TP
instead of just closing out the trade
and taking those profits? Just like ICT
says, no trader went broke taking
profits, yeah? So,
there you have it. And you actually see
what price does, it actually comes back
up and you would have been stopped out
break even. That is a perfect example of
how I trailed and managed my position on
that trade. You can go back and watch it
live. So, just to break it down, we
obviously had the model of shift in
market structure, inverse that bullish
order block, breaker block paired with
the fair value gap. So, then once we
took the first short-term low, we
trailed to the recent high. It then took
the next couple short-term lows. And
yes, you could go break even there and
basically trailing into a tiny profit.
However, I wasn't, you know, I didn't
really care about securing that tiny
profit and I would have been very happy
with taking that small loss from what
was originally at full risk just to make
sure that price is actually
disrespecting all these confluences. Cuz
when you have one, two, three short-term
lows plus a bullish order block, plus a
bearish fair value gap, which was
originally respected, you know,
that's something you got to look at and
tell yourself, "Okay, I'm happy to have
this little bit of risk on." That's one
scenario of where your thought process
as a trader comes into play. Okay, so
next example, this is actually the most
recent win I've taken, Monday, the 4th
of May. This was a trade that ran for
125 handles. So, absolutely huge gains.
But simple stuff, shift in market
structure. We had that sweep of sell
side and from the left of London lows,
stops at the lower TP at the high. Okay,
so how are we going to trail this
position? So, firstly, our job now as a
trader is to look how we're going to
manage this trade. And is our stop loss
in the correct position? Take profit in
the correct position? First trail point,
break even, not ES take profit. Identify
this high on NQ. There you go. Hover
over it, you'll see it on ES.
It's right here. So, that's final
objective. So, then you can mark out as
final
objective.
Okay, that first short-term high, that's
where I'm going to look to trail my
stop, so we can just put down as TS. And
then you can see here in this scenario,
this point here is 50% between our entry
and take profit. So, this is a nice
clean area to use
as our break-even point. So, you can put
this here as BE.
So, price respects that bullish order
block, and then it takes out that first
short-term high, and what to put in a
short-term low. So, this is where we
would slightly reduce risk
and trail our stop-loss
to that short-term low. So, there we go.
We slightly trailed stops from a full
risk to a slightly reduced risk. All
right, and there we go. So, price takes
out break-even. That's now where you'd
go risk-free, 100% going risk-free
there. In this scenario, many times
before,
price takes out the short-term highs,
and then I would trail to the short-term
lows. But, here's the thing. Where our
entry is, it's in a very, very good
position, okay? So, we're resting where
my actual entry was on the day, it was
just below this gap, this breakaway gap.
And if you actually look on the 5-minute
time frame,
price has actually put in a 5-minute
bullish gap. So, we're also resting
below that, too. So, we've already shown
that we have very bullish price action
because if you actually look here, we
have this bullish order block resting to
the left, and it's perfectly respecting
it
within price action right now. So, this
bullish order block's been respected. We
have one, two, three previous short-term
lows, and we have a 5-minute bullish
gap. So, do I want to be aggressive and
trail my stop-loss, or do I want to give
price the chance to actually move and
take out the points it needs to, and
then let it give the chance to run up
higher? So, I was basically expecting on
the day price sold off throughout the
whole of that New York AM session,
taking out points of sell-side and sell
stops. So, I was expecting a little
retracement within this period, which is
why I was so confident it was going to
go up and actually take my take profit.
I just needed to give price enough room
to breathe. Okay, you can see here that
little drop down lower, slightly big
wick. That was price tapping into that
5-minute bullish gap. So, if we go to
the 5-minute time frame, this is our
5-minute bullish gap. And you can see
how it just tapped into it, respected
it, and now we should trade out of that
point. Okay, so from this point, I'm
still not going to trail my stop loss
because, you know, at this point of
price, I'm still telling myself, you
know, I've waited this long for out the
trade. I'm not going to be aggressive
just as of yet. I'm going to let price
still do its thing. We have a bullish
order block here that price is
respecting. We have one, two, three
previous short-term lows, and price
still responding out of that 5-minute
bullish gap. And also the bullish
confluences to the left that I used for
bias at the time of this trade. So,
let's see how it goes. So, price
respects those points, and now we're
finally starting to see a distribution
higher. And this is where now I'll start
to trail my stop aggressively, and I put
it just at this low right here. So,
price respects this bullish order block
to the left. We have a lovely little
tram candle higher, and then the next
candle
bang, smashes TP. Now, you can go back
and actually look at me take this
execution live. Okay, so we've got
another example here. This is in the PM
macro, Thursday, the 23rd of April. We
have a shift in market structure by NQ
and ES. We're looking for longs of the
most recent first presented gap. Running
my stop loss at a recent short-term low.
So, there we go. There's our entry.
Okay, so we've entered into this trade.
So, how are we going to manage it?
Taking the position. All right, so we've
entered the position. Now, what we're
going to do? Same exact system applies.
Is our stop placement correct? TP
placement, first trail point,
break-even, and then our ES take profit.
So, this is our first trail point, so we
can mark this out as TS. Then this is
the short-term high. That's 50% of the
way between our entry point and TP.
Okay, there we go. So, price wicks the
first short-term high. So, I'm going to
trail my stop loss there to the most
recent short-term low. There we go. So,
price trades up that bullish order
block, taking out the next high. Okay,
so this same break-even point two, we
can mark it out on the S&P 500, which is
this point right here. So, what I can
see here is the way that price failed to
take this high on NQ here, and then it
took this high on ES. This is an
internal high. So, what I wouldn't want
to see is price actually come down
lower. So, in this scenario, I would
just go completely break even because,
you know, just based off it was very
close off that high, and it's taken a
significant area. There is a chance that
I'd see price come lower, and I wouldn't
be shocked if it did come down and
destroy break even. So, for that reason
there, I am going break even. So, now
we're going to look at how we would
trail our stop loss correctly. Okay, so
price takes out this short-term high and
this short-term high. So, I'm actually
going to trail my stop loss now into a
tiny profit just below this short-term
low here, and which is also resting just
below this bullish order block. If price
is going to move algorithmically and go
higher, it's going to respect these
bullish confluences. Okay, there we go.
So, price has taken
two short-term highs. So, my stop
placement would be just two previous
short-term lows below, just below this
one and this one. How it took out this
recent low, which is also a bullish
order block to the left right here. So,
from here, price shouldn't come down to
take out our stop loss resting below
this short-term low. It should just
accelerate higher. There we go. So, now,
this is a distribution where we have an
acceleration higher in price. So, I
would actually move my stop loss more
aggressively towards this short-term low
here. I wouldn't want to see it come
lower cuz we have one, two,
is that three? Three bullish fair value
gaps. Yeah. So, I wouldn't want to see
it go higher than that. And it's also
inverse this bearish order block to the
left here and the recent low, which was
here, got swept. So, this is a breaker.
So, price will be responding off three
gaps and a breaker block to go higher.
So, there we go. So, the price is now
accelerating higher, taking out one, two
next short-term highs. So, I'd move my
stop loss to this short-term low right
here. There we go. Just like that, we
got taken out at that point just there.
So, you'll then see from here
price would come all the way down and
take you out at break even. So, that's
exactly how you perfectly would have
managed that trade in the PM session of
Thursday, 23rd of April. And hopefully
that makes sense. So, although we didn't
go all the way up, we actually went up
and took our break even and came lower.
We went break even much, much, much
earlier. Now, you're probably wondering
why I run such a big stop placement.
It's simply because I just want to be
safe and have it at point where I'd know
that if price does come down and take me
out, then I'm 100% wrong. I don't want
to get taken out just for the sake of
having a better risk to reward and then
it take me out and actually go higher
and my idea was correct. Stop loss at
the most recent short-term low, TP at
the New York open high.
So, now you're probably looking at this
too and thinking, "Okay, so why are you
taking this long when ES has taken the
final objective?" ES didn't actually
take final objective, you can see here.
It actually made equal highs. And in
order for it to actually have taken an
objective, it needs to actually break
through the high. So, just wicking the
high or, you know, creating equal highs
was valid for me to have taken this. So,
we can see here, we take the position,
run the stop loss at the low, TP at the
high.
So, now we're going to go over our
checklist. So, stop placement, correct.
TP placement, final objective, we don't
have one. We're going to go over that.
Now, trail stops.
This is going to be our trail point. And
now,
here's the scenario of the fact that we
don't have any short-term highs to go
break even off. So, what we're going to
do? This is where the Fibonacci tool
comes into play. So, what you're going
to do is you're going to drag the fib
from your TP point to your entry or the
other way around, it doesn't really
matter, and you're going to mark out the
0.5% area. 0.5.
And if price takes out this point and
then puts in a bullish imbalance, that
will be initiating that price wants to
go higher, so we shouldn't be coming
down lower. So, that would be where I'd
go break even. So, what do you do if ES
has no final objective? Is you go and
actually look at different POIs for
where you'd want to see ES actually go
and take in order to then close out the
position. So, what I done was I went on
the 5-minute time frame and I looked at
this 5-minute bearish gap. And if ES had
come up and filled the range of this
5-minute bearish gap, I would have gone
I would have closed out my position
there because it's a higher time frame
imbalance and if price fills that range,
a lot of the time you do see price
filling the ranges of these gaps and
then it reversing. So, that was one
point I was looking at. And then I was
also looking at the next 5-minute swing
high, which was this point right here.
So, if ES had also gone up to take out
7166,
I would also have closed out the
position there, too. Okay, instantly
here we can see, same as the last
position, price takes out the first
short-term high, we put in a new
short-term low, so we're going to trail
to this short-term low, instantly
reducing risk.
Okay, so we can see here that ES has
taken out that next 5-minute swing high,
which was 7166.75,
and it's also put in a breakaway gap on
NQ. So, we've actually got a model
inside the model, shifting market
structure. So, the original bullish
model, shifted market structure, fair
value gap, tap on the gap, and then here
we've got a shift again through this
short-term high, inversing this bearish
order block, and price initiating that
is giving bullish structure. It's
responding off bullish structure,
respecting it and going higher. So, this
is a completely valid point to be going
break even.
And there we have it. So, price taps
into this bullish gap. I should then
trade higher. There we go. Price takes
out the first short-term high again
after trading out that gap. So, what we
then want to see here, okay? So, I'm not
going to trail my stop to this low as of
yet. I want to see it come lower. It
could potentially sweep this low and tap
in this gap and go higher. So, I'm not
going to trail just as of yet. Okay. So,
now price has definitely start trading
higher and we're getting close to our
take profit. I'm then going to trail my
stop loss.
So, this short-term low, which is also
the low of
this bullish order block. And then from
this point here, we could see that price
tapped into that 5-minute bearish gap.
And then on NQ2, if we go on the
5-minute time frame, it was trading out
of this 5-minute bearish order block to
left here.
So, in these scenarios, especially when
you have no final objective, real final
objective on ES, and if that's even
taken, you don't want to risk just a
couple points
just for the sake of hitting TP.
When the majority of my profit's been
hit,
I'm just going to close out there. Like
I said again, no trader ever went broke
taking profits.
Now, this does go and hit final TP, but
I think I closed out about around the
high of this candle. So, I secured the
majority of these gains. I think it was
like a 1.8R or something like that. So,
I missed out on 0.2R. So, this is
another slide of the checklist that I
use in order to manage my trades. So,
number one, stop placement, take profit
placement, your first trail point, so
that short-term high or short-term low,
identify where break even is. Okay, do
you have a short-term high or low, which
is 50% of your break even and TP? Okay.
If you got that, perfect. If not, use
the Fibonacci tool and you do it from
your entry point to your Use the
Fibonacci tool, you do it from your TP
to your entry point or entry to TP, it
doesn't really matter. You also identify
the same high if you do have one or low,
which is on the ES. So, if price takes
that, too, you can go break even that.
So, I hope you guys have enjoyed this
video. If you did find it helpful, make
sure to drop a like. Subscribe if you're
new, and drop down a comment below what
other videos you would want to see and
you want to learn. Yeah, because I'm
open to whatever new ideas to help you
guys learn. And if you are looking to
get live updates of when I'm dropping
videos, pre-market analysis, how to get
into the VIP Discord, there's a free
Discord down below where you get all
that information and you can talk with
me direct there, too. If you do want to
go inside the VIP server to watch me
trade live and take these executions
every day, all the information is there,
too. Or you can take the other link,
which takes you directly to the website.
So, I hope you guys have enjoyed this
video, and I'll catch you in the next
one. Peace.